والحرب في اوكرانيا رفعت من اسهم الاسلحه
بشكل عام حيث باتت عمله مطلوبه فالقوه
الاوكرانيه تستفادت من امدادات ضخمه من
الاسلحه سيما من الولايات المتحده التي قد
لا تستمر في دعمها بنفس الوتيره المرتفع
وذلك بسبب حجم الانتاج وهذا ما حذر منه
وزير البحريه الامريكيه كارلوس درتورو حيث
اكد ان استمرار الدعم لاوكرانيا سيكون
صعبا اذا لم يكثف صانع الاسلحه الانتاج في
الاشهر السته المقبله هذا وتعمل وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه عن كتب مع صناع الاسلحه
لزياده في تحفيزهم على زياده معدلات
الانتاج الخاصه بهم سيامو ان حاجيات
المؤسسات العسكريه الامريكيه من امدادات
الاسلحه كبيره ايضا
ووجهت وزاره البحريه الامريكيه انتقادات
للشركات المنتجه المنتجه للاسلحه لعدم
الالتزامها بالمواعد النهائيه لتسليها
ونقلا عن البحريه الامريكيه فان سلسله
التوريد قد تطرب اذا استمر الصراع في
اوكرانيا لمده سته اشهر اخرى وكانت صناعه
الاسلحه في الولايات المتحده قد تاثرت
بشكل كبير بجائحه كورونا حيث توقفت الكثير
من المصانع عن الانتاج لمده اشهر